this video is brought to you by magic
spoon
[Music]
hey wisecrack michael here we're brought
here today because of the most hyped
release of 2020
cyberpunk 2077. oh
um sorry um wrong thing the other hyper
release
the vaccines for coven 19. and with the
miracles of modern science comes people
screaming that inoculation against a
deadly disease is
fascist now there's too much being said
and done by anti-vaxxers to cover in one
video
and maybe that stuff is the topic for
another video or two
or a feature-length documentary but
today i want to focus on the history of
anti-vaxxers especially in america
to try to figure out just where it all
came from because
people being furious about vaccines is
no historical oddity
it's not enough to just reduce it to
people are dumb
instead we can learn a lot about our own
flawed healthcare system
healthcare workers began lining up to
get the vaccine
first come first serve and turns out
there wasn't even enough vaccine for
everybody who made it here
and our national love of grifters by
trying to answer the question
anti-vaxxers what went wrong
and before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
magic spoon breakfast is one of the best
and most important meals of the day
there are so many options and who
doesn't love a bowl of cereal
i love it until halfway through the day
when i crash from my sugar high
so many store-bought cereals are just
pure sugar and are filled with
junk they don't really help you feel
energized or fueled for the day
that's just one reason why magic spoon
is great
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb gmo free and most
importantly
delicious last time i talked about the
four original flavors
cocoa fruity frosted and blueberry but
now
you can get the two new flavors peanut
butter and cinnamon
if you really want to start off your
year with some healthier choices
then i definitely recommend trying it
out for yourself click the link in the
description to get some magic spoon
cereal
today you can get five dollars off your
build your own variety box by using code
wisecrack at checkout
choose the flavors you want to try and
check it out
magic spoon is so confident in their
cereal they've backed it with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it
they'll refund you no questions asked
click the link in the description and
use code wisecrack at checkout for five
dollars off or go to
magicspoon.com wisecrack now
back to the show part one the rise of
vaccines
before we can understand the modern day
backlash against vaccines
we need to look at how they became
widely popular in america in the first
place
the basic premise behind vaccination
that you can become immune from a
disease by exposing yourself to a
pathogen
goes back at least a thousand years to
china there
the dried scabs of smallpox victims
would be ground up and blown into the
noses of
children you know what they say if
you've ever done a line of coke off a
toilet seat in a public bathroom
don't worry about what's in the smallpox
nose powder the technique spread and was
tweaked as
hundreds of years later the ottomans
decided to jab people under the skin
rather than giving them a little nose
candy this technique or at least
a similar one of a different origin made
its way to america when an enslaved
african named onesimus was
gifted to one cotton mather the salem
witch trial guy onyssimus taught mather
how to immunize people against smallpox
what's called
varialation and mather spoke to other
enslaved africans who had undergone the
process
and knew it worked later doctors like
john feuster
figured out that exposure to smallpox
less crappy bovine cousin
cowpox would grant immunity against the
nastier disease
edward jenner would go on to inoculate
people with said cow pox
calling his procedure vaccination from
the latin word
vecca cow as soon as the smallpox
inoculation became a thing it started
changing history
around the time this jenner business was
happening americans would lose the
invasion of quebec
after a smallpox outbreak decimated
american troops and
not their immunized foes napoleon
understanding the strategic benefit of
vaccination
mandated the procedure for his troops
and thomas jefferson
ever the curious mind did medical
experiments on his slaves to see if the
vaccination would work
yikes of course once people like mather
and jenner started advocating for
vaccines and variations
people started getting very very mad at
them
when mather started spreading the gospel
of varialation in america
his compatriots accused him of spreading
smallpox with the procedure
someone even threw a grenade into his
bedroom window
that didn't explode it had a note
reading cotton mather
you dog damn you i'll inoculate you with
this
with a pox to you in jenner's england
critics responded to his cowpox derivex
scene with comics like this
featuring people sprouting many cows
from their butt cheeks and mouth holes
later there were also anti-vaccine riots
in places like virginia in the 1760s
it's easy to dismiss this response as
superstition or
sheer stupidity and in some cases
superstition and ignorance do play a
huge role
but there's more to it instead we have
to understand the tangled web of
mistrust and greed that breeds
resistance to vaccines
and a big chunk of that resistance today
and hundreds of years ago
was spawned by a distrust of the
government sometimes justified
and sometimes not take napoleon
bonaparte who mandated vaccination among
troops for strategic purposes
he admired edward jenner he went on to
say ah
jenner i can refuse him nothing but
after napoleon's fall
the french became wary of everything
that smacked of his dictatorship that
included the smallpox vaccine a distrust
that would contribute to their loss in
the franco-prussian war
half a century later in england
according to vaccine historian stuart
bloom mandatory vaccine laws were a
minor inconvenience to those who could
afford their own medical care
everyone else was instructed to be
vaccinated for free
but the whole operation was run by the
deeply hated
poor law guardians the resentment came
from working class people about the
growing
disciplining of the body exerted by the
british state
the netherlands also saw an anti-vaccine
backlash
but importantly bloom notes in europe it
was often a resistance to compulsion
not the vaccines themselves that is
people are more pissed about being told
what to do
later in america not surprisingly
popular support for vaccines
boomed at a time when trust for
government was at an all-time high
during world war ii as historian elena
konis writes
news reports posted that thanks to
vaccines american troops were safe from
tetanus
pneumonia yellow fever and other
infectious diseases
considering that many wars saw death
from infectious disease outnumber
actual combat deaths this was no minor
accomplishment
as conus writes vaccines were woven into
the narrative americans told
about how scientific and technological
prowess had made the united states the
leader of the free world
back home citizens were happy to do
their part to maintain a war-ready
populace by getting their immunizations
in 1943 one poll found 90 percent of
people trusted in vaccines when a
smallpox outbreak occurred in new york
city four years later
over six million people lined up to be
voluntarily vaccinated
over the next few decades america would
go april for vaccines
and to be fair most people today are
still pretty jazzed about
not getting polio we obviously still
live in a world where vaccine acceptance
is the norm
which brings us to today and how our
modern medical system helped
birth the anti-vaxxer movement part two
the rise of the modern anti-vaxxer in
the 1960s a new narrative emerged that
would define vaccine criticism for
decades to come
before we get into that a note about
terms i use the term anti-vaxxer to
describe
a group of activists that others might
call vaccine critics
there are a lot of reasons people don't
vaccinate their children from
the medically recognized kind in
consultation with doctors to
vaccine hesitancies sometimes as a
result of anti-vaxx propaganda two
the new vaccines are bad crowd to the
full-blown all vaccines are bad crap
when i say anti-vaxxer i mean people
involved with and engaged in spreading
anti-vaccine pseudoscience
people like jim carrey and jenny
mccarthy are anti-vaxxers not because
they hate all vaccines including polio
what are you against don't vaccinate for
this but vaccinate for that yes but
because they're part of a network of
activists that spreads vaccine
misinformation
much of this movement sucks because of a
simple fact doctors historically
kind of suck the medical profession
which for much of history was run by
exclusively male doctors was often
dismissive of female patients complaints
and didn't feel the need to treat them
as humans capable of having a say in
their
own health care decisions what's more
women's very real medical problems were
frequently attributed to that blanket
word
hysteria slang for your uterus is making
you crazy
in the 1960s feminist activists raised
awareness about the dangers of drugs
commonly prescribed to women like oral
contraception
dangers that were often never
communicated by the doctors prescribing
them
or the pharmaceutical companies
manufacturing them a congressional
hearing over the safety of
the pill led to one expert saying
estrogen is to cancer what
fertilizer is to wheat prompting women
to angrily ask
why are you using women as guinea pigs
one of the responses to this whole
doctors don't take us seriously and
routinely don't give us enough
information to make our own decisions
was to recenter medical expertise within
women themselves
a sentiment expressed in phrases like
mother knows best
this divide is evident for instance in
the documentary
dpt vaccine roulette a catalyst for much
of the modern anti-vaccine movement
while the documentary features
scientists and experts explaining the
safety of the pertussis vaccine
it juxtaposes them with mothers and
their disabled children
as if to make the central conflict
doctors and the women they don't take
seriously
it's a recurring motif to this day the
days of paternalism
in medical policy are over people are
taking control of their own health
the uncomfortable relationship between
predominantly male doctors
and their female patients is also clear
when for instance
jenny mccarthy invokes the concept of
refrigerator moms
a since discredited medical theory that
blames emotionally unavailable mothers
for their child's autism
we were known as refrigerator mothers
cold and uncaring to our children
we'll take a look around i believe
science was wrong
yet again similar themes come up in the
black community where vaccine hesitancy
can run high
when asked those hesitancies are often
grounded in a cultural distrust of the
government
or influenced by the dark history of
medical experimentation on the black
community
including but not limited to the
tuskegee syphilis experiments or
just old tommy jefferson testing his
smallpox vaccine on 200 people 80 of
which were his slaves
while the source of the distrust may
often be well-founded the response
sometimes isn't when talking about
doctors giving poor treatment to women
the pseudoscience it inspires often
fails to understand the ongoing struggle
of people within the medical community
to make it better as in real doctors and
nurses with
actual medical training and activists
who aren't trying to get you to do a
juice cleanse
the movement against doctor paternalism
has stress patient autonomy and joint
decision making
the kind of thing where a doctor might
lay out the various options you have and
help you make your own decisions
in the meantime people have been
radicalized away from science-based
medicine
towards homeopaths and people hawking
dangerous bleach cures
proponents will offer the common refrain
that at least in contrast to doctors
these people make their patients feel
heard i i think then it's not enough to
mock people who turn to homeopaths get
me some wolf spain also known as monk's
hood in here
and a whole tray of flour remedies but
look long and hard about why they turn
there in the first place
and the answer is clear our medical
systems need a lot of work
and just like dictators make people
distrust all kinds of governments
bad doctors make people distrust all
kinds of medical practices
this is not the only case of real
concerns over a real thing having led
people to fortify themselves into even
worse ideas
you might have heard that vaccine
manufacturers are lying to us for
money and well i think the story of how
private companies kill public vaccines
is kind of relevant part three money
at the turn of the 20th century america
was being transformed from a place where
bloodletting still happened
into a powerhouse of medical research
that rivaled its european peers
that of course included researching and
making vaccines
and a lot of that was being done outside
of private companies
in 1895 for instance the new york
department of health was producing and
distributing an anti-toxin for
diphtheria
a method learned from european
scientists that was then spread freely
to other health departments and private
companies in the u.s
but all this government's doing vaccines
thing wasn't good
business for the nascent pharmaceutical
industry so they set out to
undermine the public part of public
health they would criticize municipal
facilities for being inadequate which
may or may not have been true because
they also poached their best scientists
with lucrative salaries
they'd also say the government was
undercutting the commercial market
which is funny because it was publicly
funded research that generally got them
into the vaccine business to begin with
this didn't kill public health at least
right away as late as the 1950s and 60s
the spirit of scientific cooperation
survived as bloom writes
the flows of virus strains or know-how
were scarcely hindered by commercial
interest
but the you can't trust the shoddy
vaccine work of the government narrative
would
really start paying off in the 1980s as
bloom writes
free market advocates would cast doubt
on public sector vaccine producers by
suggesting they were made in
outdated facilities or lacked
independent regulation
by 1996 the state of michigan owned the
only public vaccine producer when it was
put up for sale
it was the country's only licensed
producer of an anthrax vaccine which
didn't enter
private buyers until fears of
bioterrorism fueled commercial interest
in 1998.
it was also in the 80s with the passing
of the bi-doll act the vaccines turned
from a
good for humanity into intellectual
property bloom argues
politicians favored market solutions and
script public health institutions of
funding and as a result
the ability to deal with urgent public
health issues you know like a future
pandemic
the head of the cdc has said recently
that it's been chronically
underfunded for years by different
administrations the lack of public
health infrastructure is why for
instance
a huge part of vaccine distribution in
the u.s will rely on private companies
like walgreens and cvs
it also can help us understand why the
u.s seems to be chronically behind on
vaccinations since
most public infrastructure that could
even store or distribute the vaccine
has long since disappeared now i don't
think that if public health departments
were cranking out a coveted vaccine
that anti-vaxxers would simply go away
as scholar anna kirkland notes
a substantial part of the anti-vaccine
movements also opposes public health
measures
that would empower the government
however anti-vax propaganda about greedy
companies
seems a lot more plausible when people
are aware of the very real cases of
deceit in the industry
deceit like when glaxosmithkline paid
the largest fine ever for fraudulent
marketing and withholding safety data
about a diabetes drug or when the
sacklers in purdue pharmacy helped
create the opioid epidemic
and look nobody loves shooting on big
pharma more than i do
but at the same time it's important to
remember there exists a mind-boggling
amount of regulations on the industry
exactly because we know it's full of
profit hungry people with a
pretty weak moral compass pharmaceutical
companies have to prove their vaccines
are safe and effective
and those claims are rigorously vetted
by the last
vestiges of our public health
infrastructure but you know who doesn't
have to be rigorously vetted
your friendly neighborhood supplement
talker who has all the same claims of
curing you with none of that actually
provable scrutiny
the genesis 2 church of health and
healing is promoting this product called
master mineral solution as a cure-all
remedy
but the fda warns it's like drinking
bleach
more extreme snake oil aside the very
profitable supplement industry in
general has strongly resisted and
rigorously lobbied against any proposed
regulations
presumably for fear that they'd have to
prove anything they sell you know
actually works this situation is nothing
new in america at least
bloom writes that american opposition to
vaccines in the 1800s
unlike its european peers was largely
led by irregular physicians
who were well aware that vaccines
threatened their snake oil practice
which brings us to part four also money
but worse it's impossible to understand
anti-vaxxerism without understanding
that large swaths of its leadership
are grifters that doesn't mean every
misled parent or everyone who has shared
a dumb meme
i mean people like andrew wakefield
author of the discredited study linking
the measles mumps and rubella vaccine to
autism it turns out wakefield was
commissioned to do so by a legal firm
trying to get a fat paycheck from a
medical malpractice lawsuit
the children from his study were
directly fed to him from the lawyers
representing their families
and it turned out that some of the kids
in his small study had been referred by
a lawyer who was suing pharmaceutical
manufacturers
on the children's behalf a scientist in
wakefield's lab
even demanded his name be taking off the
studies after wakefield included
what were clearly false positives of
measles into the final paper
he also spread alarmism about the
vaccine while he was working on his
own mmr vaccine which would have become
massively profitable if he could scare
enough people into taking it
today despite losing his medical license
wakefield is a celebrity among anti-vac
circles
working on documentaries and regularly
appearing at conferences
wakefield wasn't the first or last
example where pure financial interest
drove vaccine criticism
remember our irregular physicians in the
1800s
another instructive example comes from a
periodical called
truth teller as scholar michael kinch
writes it became an anti-vaxx powerhouse
in the early 20th century it published
the work of
laura cornelia little who claimed that
the artificial pollution of the smallpox
vaccine
killed her child ironically truth teller
which regularly advertised homeopathy
opposed the pure food and drug laws
drafted in 1906 in response to upton
sinclair's
the jungle this act led to the creation
of the food and drug administration the
primary instrument
in which the government is able to hold
pharmaceutical companies accountable
today
so why would homeopaths campaign against
a call for pure food and also regulated
drug safety
because the laws also put people selling
bullsh homeopathic cures out of business
as kentrides the very real suffering and
animus felt by the followers of laura
little were exploited by the
truth-teller and laura little herself
who sold a series of additional
publications on the perils of vaccines
to a gullible public
today of course is no different as
anti-vaxx propaganda puts forward images
of suffering children to scare people
into the office of their nearest
homeopath
it is no coincidence that almost every
vaccine skeptic you see has their own
cures
from thomas maybe viruses aren't real
cowan who sells 50
beet powder to alex jones selling kovac
cures before getting a cease and desist
from the fda
to whatever the hell goop is doing
there's also the national vaccine
information center
an ironically prominent source of
vaccine misinformation
which received roughly 40 of its
operating expenses
from a single guy named joseph mercola
who made banks selling vitamin
supplements as an alternative to
vaccines
the point is if people can't
differentiate between the grip of
pharmaceutical companies price gouging
insulin and evidence-based treatment for
diabetes
and the grip of people pushing bogus
covert cures it's not just science a
literacy to blame
it's a long history of doctors being bad
at their job
medicine for profit and other grifters
casting doubt on established
institutions for their own financial
benefit
but there is still one more piece of the
puzzle i want to talk about today
part 5 choice ultimately vaccines only
work if
millions of individuals make the
personal decision to get them and we
can't talk about that personal decision
without talking about something called
neo-liberalism neo-liberalism is an
ideology that stresses that any problems
can and should be solved by a free
market rather than the government
but also on a personal level it frames
personal economic decision making as the
ultimate locus of freedom
neoliberalism is the process in which a
person celebrates their personal freedom
as they get to pick which vial of 300
insulin they want which is not to say
personal choice is bad
but as bioethicist jill fisher writes
the focus on individual
choice serves to obscure the ways in
which healthcare inequalities are
generated by the system itself
in other words medical neoliberalism
leads to a prioritization of choice
over equity and access in the context of
vaccines
neoliberalism frames vaccines as a
personal choice rather than say
a civic duty to not kill people and i
don't think it's your responsibility to
take a vaccine because i might be at the
same party with you and you might cough
on her
compare that rhetoric say to the
star-studded campaign to find a polio
cure
you know every child has a right to that
health and happiness which stress that
everyone chip in for a disease that
could strike any child
send your dimes and dollars to your
local march of dimes headquarters
help make this the victory march of
dimes
blackpink christmas on march when
anti-vaxxers in the vaccine hesitant to
talk about
the exceedingly rare complications from
vaccines it's always framed as a direct
risk
to their child this is done while
ignoring how vaccines are a kind of
social contract benefiting everyone yes
a person can skip a measles vaccine and
not worry too much about getting measles
from their vaccinated peers and this
might be an
economically rational decision in the
same way that cutting in line works
great if you're the only one doing it
which you're not once declared
eradicated in the united states
measles outbreaks are rattling regions
of the country again this year but it's
not just that this mindset hinders our
ability to think about how our actions
might affect our friends or community
it also creates a narrative where doing
the civic minded thing is
lazy and bad anna kirkland describes a
general anxiety around mothers
especially affluent mothers
to do everything in their personal power
to make sure their kids are eating right
avoiding carcinogens and other toxins
and overall just being healthy anything
less is being a
bad and lazy mother it's this mentality
which can seduce people
doing the normal thing is easy and
therefore not enough finding a bunch of
misinformation on google and buying your
kid
weird supplements is active and good
vaccines kirkland notes are for everyone
and they work on the children of both
super moms and slacker moms the fact
that vaccines create an immune response
in nearly everyone
means that they cannot constitute
individual health achievement through
doing the right
things author seth manukin calls some of
the anti-vaxxer logic
medical nimbyism a reference to the
maligned not in my backyard kind of
social activism that says
i don't want a garbage dump in my
backyard of course that said with the
tacit understanding
that they very much don't care when it
ends up in someone else's
we might think about how affluent
parents with secured jobs can take a
week off work to care for an ailing
child
but that ailing child can infect the
children of poorer parents
who for example might have to take an
unpaid week off work and even end up in
medical debt
or in some context free riding off the
hurt immunity of others
while foregoing the extremely rare risk
that vaccines pose
i would probably advise against it if
the rest of the community were getting
the pertussis
so much of anti-vaxx concern trolling
juxtaposes the extremely small chance a
child in america will die
from things like measles or pertussis
but this glibly ignores the reality
almost no american children die of
pertussis exactly because
most americans get vaccinated against it
there's no
more polio in the united states and
there's no more diphtheria in the united
states and
no one no child has contracted
wild polio since 1979. as manuka notes
the notion that people should base
medical decisions on what is right for
them
is particularly problematic in a public
health context where individual choices
cannot be cordoned off from each other
this is not to deny the importance of
things like patient autonomy
but unfortunately anti-vaxxers have
stretched the concept to only its most
selfish meaning
ironically a more reasonable group of
people who don't like to get vaccinated
can be found in the community-oriented
amish after a polio outbreak spread in
amish communities in 1979
they reversed course and vaccinated
their kids correctly realizing that they
posed a risk to people outside of their
own community
the same mentality of seeing individual
public health choices as only affecting
the one decision maker
also rears its head in the anti-mask
movement not surprisingly it's a
movement spurred on by prominent names
in the anti-vaccine movement
and of course this all gets wrapped up
with a general distrust of the
government
which again does all kinds of other
terrible things on a regular basis
as we plow headfirst into 2021 it will
be interesting to see if the anti-vaxxer
movement thwarts our attempts at herd
immunity or if we'll all get to make out
with strangers at the vanilla ice
concert but either way
we should look out for how even the
worst reactions to problems can still
point to real problems and how we can
fix them
does our medical system need work yes
have we done some awful things in the
past
hell yes does this mean i should trust
an mlm for all my healthcare needs
no dear god no but what do you think
is roasting jenny mccarthy a public
health service or does it miss the point
entirely
let us know what you think in the
comments big thanks to our patrons for
all your support
annihilate that subscribe button like
during 97 effective vaccine stamping out
the hopefully worst pandemic of our
lifetime
and ring that bell like it's closing
time at a bar full of inoculated
drunkards
and as always thanks for watching later
[Music]